there's a level above the extreme
realist which is what i call the curious
competitor which they're actually
seeking out adversity they're seeking
out challenges they're seeking out
hardship
they're seeking out the hard
conversations they're seeking out the
discipline
because they know it's only through
those actions
that they forge their character
mr ben bergeron welcome to the show hi
chris glad to be here
i'm really happy to have you here man
it's been a long a long time planning
very glad that we finally got to sit
down well that's because you were
traveling the world
and it's hard to get you to sit settle
down and from your adventures
that's true dubai was dubai was fun
briefly today i want to
dig into your principles for excellence
this is like your
your specialist subject right uh i don't
think i'm a specialist in anything i'm a
generalist i would say
yeah and and and i and excellence
i don't think it's like an oxymoron
right like you can't be a specialist in
excellence because it's so
elusive it's like you
that's why it's it's the idea is like to
chase it it's not to own it like you
can't you're not going to get there
so at least i'm not there
[Laughter]
all right what so what does excellence
mean to you
like what is it yeah it's a um it's a
good question
i i you know in real time i'm going
through my head right now i was like you
should have a good answer for this and i
don't
it's like i wrote a book called chasing
excellence and you ask what is
excellence
ah wow that's yeah something i should
have an answer to
but really it's um it's it's a catch-all
term for
um greatness it's a term for
um achieving what you want to achieve
it's life
on your terms it's uh world-class
it's um um
being incredibly proud of something um
and i think that it's it's supposed to
be
um like yeah you can put all these like
what is you know
um you know it goes from the spectrum of
like
world class to like bill and ted's
excellent adventure you know
slang word to whatever it means whatever
you want to mean
to me though when i say the word
excellence
it means um like the best of your
ability
that's what it really means is like and
that's why it's about
chasing that because you're never
you know called maximizing your
potential if you want to which is a
complete unknown no one knows how much
potential they have or what they're
actually capable of and you could also
argue that people like
every now and then exceed their
potential in some extenu
you know extraordinary circumstances
people actually
perform better than they are capable of
because they get
um whatever these magical powers are
that people can lift a car off
of a child whatever it might be or um
you know there's these
kind of moments that people have when
they get to these incredibly deep flow
states where
um they they they magnify their own
abilities by twofold whatever it might
be
so i'm not so interested
in the definition of what excellence is
i'm more interested in what are the
practices that we should put into our
everyday lives to get as close to
whatever that term might be as possible
because whether it's fulfillment
whether it's success on your terms of
success on society's terms
whether it's winning whether it's um
freedom whether it's uh the disciplined
pursuit
of less whether it's it's kind of like
it's up for you to decide what
excellence is
and then the pursuit of that
is fairly
consistent across all those different
different domains right it's
it's i'm not writing anything that
anybody that's kind of dabbled in this
world like i'm not doing anything unique
i'm just putting it through the prism
of a coach that's it like i'm taking the
same things that i've been talking about
for years whether you talk about it from
the the early stoics to the monks
to the um abraham lincoln to
the ryan holidays to the james clears to
the stephen coveys to the
it's all like the the same
um principles put into action it's just
i'm putting through my own like little
prism and things that i've found worked
and um i'm learning a lot more than
you know continually and you know when i
wrote the book
i don't even know when i guess it was
2016 and that's five years ago
there's a lot of things in the book that
i'm like i i
i'm not like damn i wish i didn't write
that but it's i like i don't agree with
it anymore
you know there's some interesting things
that i've like i've just changed
perspective on
what are some of those
i i put in the book like one of the
tenants you know so basically the book
that i wrote
it's called chasing excellence and it's
these um
you know half dozen or a dozen or so
different
characteristics or principles that
people
at the time i was saying that these are
kind of the tenets these are like the
things that people need to have in order
to become
quote unquote excellent um and things
like that things have changed like one
of the ones i said was positivity
and um the idea behind that was people
that are in a positive mindset
you know i know you're preparing for to
give a ted talk so when you go on stage
if you're in a positive frame of mind
you're you're you're a lot more likely
to knock it out of the park than you are
if you go out there and like i'm going
to [ __ ] this up this can be terrible
like
oh my god what if i stumble on my words
what if i forget my words like it's kind
of obvious right everyone knows that
that's like success literature 101
visualization 101
but what's interesting is when you kind
of dig into it
there's a case to be made for negativity
so in terms of prisoners of war
people with a negative mindset live
longer than the optimists
the pessimists live longer than the
optimus the optimists say we'll be
and this is the stockdale paradox this
is uh there's a lot of examples of this
but you know basically the people that
live the longest the ones
um it's not the people that are like
it's okay
we'll be out by christmas because
christmas comes and goes and they're
still in
prison that's like okay we'll be up by
easter easter comes and goes and
they're still in prison and also it
rolls around to next christmas and
they diet you know they they die of a
broken heart
well it's also not the pessimist that's
kind of obvious like a pessimist
is not the optimal state to be in either
because
the pessimist goes this sucks so bad
like i can't believe this and
they just end up eating themselves alive
of negativity and they're not going to
thrive you can't thrive in a negative
mindset
but you could also create that same
parallel to let's say you have a
your your um
your per you're three months out from
your ted talk
when you're three months out from your
ted talk i'd rather have you have a
negative mindset
because we have a negative mindset
you're gonna think about all the
different
things that can go wrong and you're
gonna mitigate those things
but then when you walk on the floor i
want you to be in that flow saying that
positive optimal mindset
so it's not really just like positive
versus negative it's not as binary as
that
if you're a salesperson again i want you
when you're preparing for that sales
pitch
to be a little bit negative like what
are all the things that they could say
what's every question what's every hole
they could punch in our
sales presentation then we walk in the
door and be like yo we got this because
you're so prepared
the only way you're prepared is if
you've been willing to brace
for the hard stuff optimus have a
tendency to go the sun
is always going to shine the grass is
always green
there's unicorns growing in the backyard
there's rainbows everywhere
well that just is not reality like
reality is there is struggle there is
suffering there is hardship
in life so the way i would frame this
now is
there is it's not about positive or
negative
you know maybe the shakespeare thing but
um there are no there's not no such
thing as positive or negative but
thinking makes it so
so let's embrace harsh realities
let's prepare for the worst let's be
ready for
the easy roads if they come and
celebrate them along the way
but to me it's more about being an
extreme realist like i would rather have
people be a realist
than an optimist or a pessimist what i
got confused of was like when you walk
on the floor i'd rather be an
optimist and i got confused with a
little bit about like the enjoying the
journey so much
and like
for people that are trying to truly you
know another
thing i talked about was passion like
screw
passion like passion is like when people
when you find passion people are excited
for you
like chris i'm so happy that you found
something that you enjoy so much
i'm so happy for you like passion
passion passion passion passion
that's not going to get you to where you
want to go what where you want to go
is obsession like world-class like it's
reserved for people that are
obsessed and the athletes i work with i
i'm lucky to work with
you know a half dozen or so of the very
fittest people on planet earth
and i see differences inside of those
just four or five athletes of levels
of passion versus obsession the
passionate people come in and they work
their ass off
the obsessed ones go home and do film
review
and they obsess over it and they obsess
over
their nutrition and they obsess over
their recovery and they obsess over
their sleep and they obsess over
the right and i mean i'm what i'm
describing is matt fraser like that's
matt like matt left no stone unturned
the entire way along the whole thing
like every he was obsessed he
edited his life down to the things that
are going to move him closer to his
goals
and if it didn't move closer his goals
it was gone it was eliminated
and there was no second guessing it it
was a complete
obsession now if you were to go to matt
and go like are you passionate about
this may i be like no it kind of sucks
like he's not he wasn't passionate about
it but he was certainly
obsessed so there's things i've i've
i've
changed along the way which i think is
good like it's i i'm
proud of that i'm not like i'm not like
wishing that i i was still had those
thoughts because
you know one of the other things i would
have put in the book is curiosity
like curiosity to me is like one of if i
was to list like
three tenets of
um like a of character traits that
the world class have like you gotta be
curious you gotta like wanna know and
i didn't have that vocabulary i didn't
have that word one of my
um employees gave it to me we were
talking about the differences of like
world-class coaches versus good coaches
and they're like one of the things i've
seen
is this certain coaches have this level
of curiosity where they're always trying
to like
just make it better like it's just
you know i i tend to talk about like uh
excellence on a
spectrum on one end if you have
excellence in the middle you have
competence the ability to do things
and then the far end the opposite end
you would have complacency
which is like it doesn't really matter
whereas excellence is like geeking out
about
every tiny little thing it's the
obsession it's but
the only way you get from competence to
excellence
is curiosity if you're cool with being
good
like then you're cool being good and
you're not gonna you know you're
you'll stay there not right or wrong i
think you need to be
competent in most areas of your life
because you're not going to be able to
be excellent
across the board you don't need to be
excellent at doing your taxes
you just need to be complicated holy
crap i just like literally
the the call i had before this was with
my accountant
and like literally when you just said
that i was like dude what's like have
you been watching me
yeah like literally i hung up with my
account and uh i am so bad with that
crap
yeah that's yeah i um i really like the
curiosity idea it's the number it's the
first
personal value that i've got in my list
of five i love it
very cool um what are your other four uh
so it spells cases
curiosity uh i want to learn about
myself and the world around me adventure
i want to meet new people and have
experiences
selfless development i want to improve
myself and then teach other people what
i've learned
e excellence i want to i want to make
the most of my minutes i want to fulfill
my potential
and s self-care in order to be
everything i want to be for everyone
else i have to look after myself first
cases good for you man that's great
love it um yeah i think curiosity is a
very scalable way
to um constantly be pushing towards more
because curiosity is all of the good
stuff
around relentlessness without any of the
bad stuff
like the the the grinding side the
garyvee hustle and grind side of
relentlessness
is a bit that people kind of realize is
going to be the grind
but the curiosity side is just
constantly fulfilling an inquisitive
nature i want to know more i want to
know more
not i have to know more um
yeah before people even start thinking
about excellence
is there something they need to do
beforehand before they start learning
your tools and tactics and strategies
and what other tenants
do they need to do something before well
i l i love what you just laid out there
in terms of this
um it's beyond the grind right it's this
level of curiosity of just better for
betterment's sake
right it's like just the evolution of
our being so
i talk about this in terms of like the
hierarchy of mindset so
i'll get to i'll get to the question you
just asked i'm purposely i'm
i'm going to revert back to the earlier
thing you said because i think it's
really interesting
um because then it ties this
conversation together
and to me we need to give a language to
mindset
we need to be able to um create the
prism
and know where we are on the spectrum
because what everyone does is they go
resilience grit
fortitude mental toughness tenacity
like like passion perseverance
okay like what do we do with those
things like what
what do we do with that and we're and
the more you kind of
get exposed to those things it shows the
gap of where you actually are
so what i would like to know is
um for this moment that i'm experiencing
right now how am i doing
and i think about that in terms of four
different layers
four or five different layers levels
level one in the lowest level is the
victim mindset
the victim mindset you have no control
over the situation um
and you are truly just at the whim and
the mercy of the world
and you give up total control and
responsibility there's zero ownership
that's the that is the worst level and
probably people that are listening to
your podcast in mind that
they're not there but maybe in like
every now and then something like that
pops
up and like the boss says you gotta work
on the weekend and maybe they slip into
it for a minute right
it's like oh woe is me that sort of
thing
most of people though would be a little
bit above that level
um which to me is the pessimist
and the pessimist goes it's not like the
woe is me as much as it's just like ah
this sucks all right i'll work this
weekend
but it's a negative it's a negativity
they're bringing to it and what we know
is people won't perform well if they
have a negative mindset than an optimist
mindset which is the next level which is
obstacles not opportunities i'm sorry
opportunities not obstacles right you
got to work this weekend
okay got it i've got to work this
weekend that's an opportunity for me to
do this this and this
it's not so the lowest level is the
victim
the next level above that is the
pessimist the level above that
is the optimist and that's where most
people start stop
they're like we gotta surround ourselves
with positive people we gotta um
be glasses half full we gotta enjoy the
journey and all that stuff and that's
that's when i wrote my book that was
like that's the top and what i realized
is i've already alluded to it is a
little bit
i would rather have the extreme realist
you know ray dalyu's words
like which is people that embrace harsh
realities accept life for what it
is and realize that there is going to be
struggle there is going to be strife
and we can navigate it that's okay we
don't need to pretend like this doesn't
exist
like there's a pandemic okay no big deal
pandemics happen every 100 years
and this one's nowhere near as bad as
the last one totally cool
now we can still thrive in this moment
today
like babies crying in the middle of the
night victim goes
like oh my god why is my baby crying the
pessimist goes oh this sucks i'm not
gonna sleep tonight
the optimist goes it's okay maybe my
baby will stop crying in a in a minute
and the baby doesn't stop crying
obviously because the realist realizes
babies cry like that's what happens but
what you alluded to which i love
so much is the language that i've even
started using is there's a level above
the extreme realist
which is what i call the curious
competitor
which they're actually seeking out
adversity
they're seeking out challenges they're
seeking
out hardship they're seeking out the
hard conversations
because they know they're seeking out
the discipline because they know
it's only through those actions that
they forge
their character that is the actual where
you get to put
all of the practice all of the
meditation or
journaling or listening to podcasts or
self-reflection or whatever it is
that's where you actually get to put it
into practice
and people in our space like the
crossfit world know this that's why we
choose this sport
we recognize that the greatest
adaptation is between your years it's
not what the hour in the gym it's about
the how the hour in the gym
affects the other 23 hours outside the
gym
we're becoming better stronger more
formula human beings
because of the hardship that we're going
through we're not looking for the
shortcut in fact we want the opposite
we want murph in a weight vest like we
want the
hardest possible thing because we know
what's at the other side of that
a better version of myself so why would
we
shy away from the baby crying in the
middle of the night that's an
opportunity for us
to see if we can be more patient can i
be present during this moment
can i still bring love and affection to
my child in this moment
and if i can't what you alluded to it's
not a win or a loss
it's not about the leaderboard sometimes
we're not going to do great this
but it's the awareness of that journey
and that constantly walking through this
life
with that level of awareness and that
prism
that's what gets us closer to quote
unquote chasing
excellence i tweeted something the other
week
that said people are rarely fearful of
the future when they're genuinely
curious about what it holds
and this is something that i keep on
falling back to
uh it's taken a lot of time to get it
from system two to system one
but it is becoming more automated over
time and i genuinely think
when something occurs that's
uncomfortable a thought or a
the texture of my mind gets me to a
place where i don't want to be
it's almost automatic now for me to
think how interesting
like why yeah love that why is that
there
what what triggered that so earlier on
today we had like a message that pissed
me off to do with work
and i thought i noticed that i could
feel it inside me i was getting hot my
neck got hot
i remember observing it and going that's
so interesting
like i wonder why that's there there's a
story i think it's in
chasing excellence of katrin and maybe
she
was going into training and hadn't slept
very well the night before
or maybe hadn't eaten very well the
night before and
i think you said that her mindset wasn't
this training sessions are write off
it's completely pointless
it was this is a great opportunity for
me to train
at sub-optimal preparation how well can
i get through this session with that
isn't it interesting
that i have this opportunity maybe and
a couple of years later it happens maybe
we're going to be flown to the other
side of the country to go and do an
event that we weren't prepared for at
the beginning of the crossfit
games with no sleep without our food
with no coaches with no this that and
the other
and um that curiosity is so much more
scalable
it can go across every situation the
hacks and the tips and the tricks are
great
but their domain is narrow the curiosity
scales
what you um what you're highlighting
there
which is so powerful is that awareness
right that awareness that when that
trigger happens
and you get that bad email or katrin
doesn't feel like she's prepared for the
workout or
your spouse says hey we need to talk or
um
you get that bad uh comment on social
media
or whatever or someone cut you off in
traffic whatever that thing is
that gives you that like little feeling
right the power is recognizing that
that's a trigger
and it's not a tunnel a trigger is
something that sets you off but you
don't need to follow it through a tunnel
as you get in tunnel and you follow
through to the end
right it's it's a
it's a it's data it's not a decision
like it's just this feeling it's like
there's that data point huh and as you
said isn't it
interesting that that made me feel that
way well
why did it do that well there's
evolutionary biology can kind of let us
know what's going on so
what happens is in when we were like
cave men and women kicking around the
campfire it was all about survival it
was like 100 percent about survival
maslow's hierarchy of needs it was about
shelter air
food um not getting put on the
um exposed to the elements so
the biggest most powerful thing we had
there was our tribe like the tribe was
the safety
so what we were so became so innately
aware of
through our subconscious brain not
conscious it was not
like hey this person it's why trust it's
why love
are these in you can't define them you
tell me why you love your wife you can't
but you can say it's this feeling i have
those things are real it's part of the
lizard brain the limbic part of the the
emotional part of the brain
and it's really good at picking up these
signals
and what happens is as cave men and
women when a twig would go snap in the
woods you would startle flinch
it would be thought out it would just
happen to be a reaction immediately
to protect yourself because it might be
a saber-tooth tiger
that same reaction happens when maybe
you hear someone gossiping about you
because if they don't like you
if they see you as a threat or they
don't think that you're contributing to
the group
um or um you might be an outcast
they push you out of the group and
you're going to die so
the thing is those feelings don't serve
us anymore
we're not going to be pushed out of our
three-bedroom apartments with the
two-car garages
into the wild because somebody said
something bad at first on social media
yet from an evolutionary biology
perspective nothing's changed
you can you can take the the
person out of the paleolithic area but
that
the brain parts comes with it and
we are still hardwired to respond
to react to those situations
like their real life threatening events
so you get an email from somebody that
says something bad about your business
or whatever it might be
and your brain goes like
life-threatening life-threatening
when it's not it's just an opportunity
to make your business better
it's a data point it's a point of
feedback and if you didn't react to it
emotionally and said you took a
calculated
response you were responsible you took
ownership
response able able to respond
you did it calculated you did it through
a thought out process
something that you're going to be proud
of later on that's going to be
productive
those are all characteristics of
responding as opposed to
reacting which is emotional overreacting
instinctual something that you're going
to regret later on
unproductive it's the way amateurs act
one is going to serve us and one is not
it's so much more powerful for us to
take this
um this like curious approach of whoa
where'd that feeling come from isn't
that interesting
and then we can respond instead of react
it's the
single best advert or the single best
justification that i can give anybody
that's still not convinced about
meditation
that the trait change of meditation
comes very very slowly to get yourself
to the point at which you've made
a system-wide os update
to the texture of your mind it takes a
lot of time
i'm over a thousand days deep on insight
time and now
whoa good for you man yeah i mean it's
the 10 and 15 minute sessions but
still it doesn't matter like that's
concerns about frequency yeah
um and the main thing that i've got is
that
what corey allen refers to as the
mindfulness gap which is
the brief beat between stimulus and
response
just the moment where you notice the
texture before you actually decide to
react
and um even if i meditate for the rest
of my life and i don't get
any more any closer to nirvana than that
if enlightenment for me is simply not
being at the mercy of the wind as soon
as it hits
me that for me i'll consider that a win
and i think that it's
it's something that i really wish not
only that i'd had earlier in my life but
i wish it was like a gift i could give
to other people as well
um yeah that's really cool um i'm
so
i've been um very introspective for a
long time and kind of like trying to
figure out my values and principles and
who i want to be and what i want to
stand for and how i spend my time and
how i'm going to react to certain
situations and where i want to put my
energies and all that stuff
but for whatever strange reason i i
pushed off
meditation for a long time and i think
it's because
it was always
sold to me as it's a great way to become
calm and lower stress and i'm
i'm a fairly calm low stress person so i
was like i don't see
if that's if that's the carrot at the
end of the race like i
don't think it's a race worth racing
and i got i got kind of tricked into
meditation
when i started doing wim hof um so i
would start doing breathing practicing
not realizing i was going to be falling
into a meditative state
so um i'm on day about 55
of me of wimhoff consistently i've
missed i think two days along the way
and um it's a really powerful breathing
technique and then afterwards
you just you you sit in this incredibly
deep deep meditative state
and i had these amazingly powerful
awakenings really really early on and of
course like there's the roller coaster
of like
some of them suck and you wish that you
could go back to the good ones and um
it's not linear and
it's um um such as the gen
the the journey of all of our lives in
every form fashion why would meditation
be any different
um but it's again like we
i i only wish that i had found this
earlier
and the point where i'm i'm doing
research on the the super high achievers
you know 10 years ago and everybody's
journaling and everybody's meditating
and i'm like eh not for me like how
arrogant
how astonished like oh this is the best
in the world across the field
everybody's doing these two practices
but i'm like i got it
how funny man and then yeah i mean i'm
only you know and here i am again kind
of like espousing how amazing it is and
i'm only a few months into this thing
but
it's i realize how um ignorant and
arrogant i was in that
that field because i agree with you it's
it's an incredibly enlightening
um enlightening practice
the moment that you realize that you can
step into your own programming
is the day that your life changes as far
as i'm concerned
the fact that you know that you don't
have to be at the mercy
of the next thought that comes careering
into view
like it's it's like watching traffic on
a road you don't control whether the
traffic comes or goes
um but yeah so getting back to the the
excellence
discussion is commitment the foundation
that's the first chapter from chasing
excellence is that still kind of the
first tenet that people need to
take on board no so i would so and maybe
this is why
because what you just said there is like
the the when you feel like you can
control the operating system in your
inside of you like it's the first step
of the rest of your life and you
you tend to take control um i i sort of
found that a different way than
meditation so that's like i found this
through a another portal and that's
probably why i was like uh i don't need
it
so to me it starts with in terms of like
the
the pursuit of excellence it starts with
not necessarily commitment because what
the hell are you committing yourself to
like how can you how can you commit to
something where you haven't figured out
what that should be
so to me it's the it's knowing thyself
um and that what what better way to exp
to try to figure it out than
meditation and journaling um and
for that you need solitude you need the
self-reflection you need a bunch of
different things
um and that is a practice i did so i
spent a lot of time
trying to figure out um
you know what is it that is going to
make me
fulfilled and that's a word i use all
the time so if i was to write the book
again it'd be called chasing fulfillment
because that's like
that to me is the most important thing
it's not about excellence
excellence is subjective and are you
just trying to impress other people are
you looking for the applause
in the accolades are you looking for the
awards and the trophies
that to me sucks um because what you
might end up doing which a lot of people
do is they get to the top of the ladder
only to realize the ladder was leaning
up against the wrong wall like that just
that's my biggest nightmare in the world
is to be chasing
excellence to something which ultimately
does not matter like
oh my god i worked my ass off like
worked so
damn hard for what like
so my first step is i think the most
important thing is what you've done
your cases right which is established to
you
what is it that you want to um what are
the
values that you want to use to guide
your life like what do you believe in
like who are you
as a person and what do you um want to
get to the end of the race
with so otherwise what you do is you let
other people decide that for you either
the education or your parents
or the normal um the normal traditional
route
is gonna be laid out for you and you're
just gonna be
the lemming following along and maybe
you're a really good
fast slumming or you're really smart
lemming or you're really
good looking lemming but essentially
you're not making decisions to where you
want to be and
you actually have you can control the
directives of your life
and when to me it's like when you
understand that's like i talk about in
terms of like the circle of control
you know like what are the things that
you ultimately control in your life and
you have to put
all of your effort into those things in
which you can influence
and ignore everything else what i think
people don't realize is how much they
actually can
influence appear like well um
like okay so i can't i i don't like my
boss okay i can't control my boss so i'm
not gonna
worry about that like i don't like i
don't like the weather can't control the
weather so i'm not gonna worry about
that
um i would say like what are you talking
about like
you can control who your boss is
if you don't like your boss like quit
your job and get a different job
you are not a victim like if you don't
like the weather
there are plenty places in the world
that have better weather than where you
are living right now now if you live in
maui and you don't like the weather like
then you're just a pessimist and i can't
help you
but like if you don't if it's that much
if it means that much to you
take control feel like well i don't i
can't move because
um my family's here and i compare my
family okay
if that's actually true cool
like family is a real value to you
then understand why you're here and stop
complaining about something that now you
can't control
because you're going to be here and to
me it's that understanding
of what is it that really means a lot to
you what is important to you what is
your identity like
who are you for me i love your cases to
me it's the 4l's
i found that and i've fumbled through
this a bunch of different ways i've been
tracking this on a daily basis i have
about 25 things i track on a daily basis
um and it's um for me it's
it's um live love
lead and learn so you've got rid of
legacy
yeah i got rid of legacy yeah good call
wow i'm impressed um
legacy's outside my control and what
legacy to me is like do i want people to
i i was using legacy i didn't want
people to wreck statues of me i didn't
want people to write books about me when
i was gone
i and i i realized that um i'm gonna be
one generation
stardust like my kids will remember me
my grandkids
might have vague recollections of me and
after that it's done
like and anything after that it's like
it to me is all ego like you are just
trying to drive the ego and it's the
last thing i want is i'm trying to
melt my ego as much as i possibly can so
um and that legacy never was supposed to
be about that for me legacy
for me was like i want my kid i want to
be the hero of my kids lives
so i just wrapped that into love um i
to me it's the love aspect of it um
so once you kind of figure out what
those things are and it's nice to have
alliterations
or acronyms for sure um
because i think that those carry weight
because you got to be able to know them
if you're like uh
people like what are your values what's
important to you and you go hold on let
me pull up my knees you always forget
the fourth one or something
yeah yeah exactly um it's probably not
that powerful to you
so um so to me like it starts with that
it starts with like
and i i came back to this and i
eliminated um
legacy through meditation realizing like
um you know what makes me feel alive
what makes me feel alive like really
alive and for me it's like
living life for you that's adventure
that's that's me it's like have
experiences
say yes get outside go do things like
that's
living life for me so we're very similar
in that fashion
um learn is curiosity for me so it's the
same thing with me it's like
i i feel so alive when i'm um becoming
um
like honing skills and figuring stuff
out
and um um the curiosity thing is just
like that's
like curiosity is like the fastest way
into a flow state like i just love like
oh my god like
yes um love is basically
it's about me it's it's my family i love
like family
means so much to me i'm a family first
guy um
if it's um comes down to
this or that and that is family it
doesn't matter what this is
like it's gonna go away um
and then um the last ones lead which i
found is like
i like being a coach like that there's a
reason i became a coach is
i like um i i feel really good i feel
really fulfilled when i'm helping other
people
and i've tried to do this in other ways
like giving to charity or
teaching or um
it's nothing fulfills me quite as much
as the the
the leading thing it works for me in
business too so when i'm like um
you know um helping develop our staff
for whatever it might be like
i love that um aspect of things i like
the responsibility of it i like
um having um
trying my best to help other people so
to me it's that's where you start and
then from there we can get into the
commitment thing and there it becomes
like
the daily actions and then it gets into
the next stuff
let's talk about commitment how
important is it
um
if we don't commit to it what we're
doing is we're just kidding ourselves
and it's it's easy to kid ourselves
because us sitting here talking about
this right now we feel good
if you talk about your goals your body
releases dopamine
that is one of the the really scary
things about
goals if you talk about running a
marathon this year
you're gonna feel really good and you
talk about like the running program
you're gonna do
you're gonna start feeling really good
you start talking about like i'm gonna
actually do this in under four hours
you're gonna start to feel really good
you haven't done
anything yet like you've done nothing
all you're doing is kidding yourself so
i like to defuse say like it's it's
you know i can't hear what you're saying
because your actions speak so loudly
like it is only about what you commit
yourself to
so i can pretend to espouse like
leadership i can pretend to espouse like
family i can spend your spouse like
living my life
but if i'm not actually doing the daily
tasks that inch me closer to those
i'm i'm
i'm just gonna have some sort of like
salesman i'm just kind of like throwing
it out there
so i know that this is i don't even know
if this is
um i know you can see this but other
people can't i
i i started tracking my commitment to
see how committed i am
so i write down my values
and then wow um for under my values
for every day i have four or five things
for each value
and i check them off if i do them each
day and i've done this for
since um 2015.
so i'm they iterate they change they
morph their but you know
but it lets me know and when i don't do
it
guess what happens so it's it's not
rocket science either it's like it's
really simple
so like to give some context to it so um
love
to me it's about love so love is be home
by six o'clock every night
um have family dinner um contact my wife
in the middle of the day
so while i'm at work contact her before
i get home um
play with i call them the littles i have
two little kids um so play with the
littles
call my mom and dad so those are the
five things i have for love
and i'm tracking those and what i found
was those things come in and there's
other things that take their place
but what i found is when those if i
haven't done those things
consistently enough something feels
weird to me like
but if i'm doing those things that kind
of category
i'm kind of good like i'm kind of good
with that
family love thing i'm really good with
that so for leadership it's like
have a hard conversation like i actually
now seek
out a hard conversation every day like
that's what leaders do
they have hard conversations with people
the next one is like connect like
emotionally
empathetically whatever is with an
employee so with somebody on my team
another one is connect with a
member so connect with somebody
that works out at the gym another one is
thought leadership which is code word
for me it's like i
i give a talk after my classes and when
i give when i don't give a talk it
doesn't feel like i've given everything
i have to it
but the talks are hard i have to prepare
for them and um
and the last one is which i found is um
leaders need to be prepared
so did i prepare for a meeting today
that i'm gonna have tomorrow because
otherwise
the last thing you want to do as a
leader is walk into the area where
you're supposed to be the leader and be
unprepared so that to me is like
the commitment thing it's like are you
actually doing it so people have core
values
organizations have them and what they
fail to do is operationalize them okay
you got these cool things that you said
are important to you
like we are about integrity we are about
faith we are about
um customer service we are about
whatever it is
and they just leave them there up on the
wall
and they forget to operationalize them
and it's
only when you operationalize them that
they mean anything that's the commitment
aspect
that's when it comes to fruition that's
when you're actually taking steps
forward
what does maximizing minutes mean
um so in stoic philosophy i'm gonna
butcher it but it's amura fatih
i believe it is which um um
is that love thy fate love thy fate yeah
uh no it's the other one
it's the one uh so there's a two sides
of it it's the uh
um butchering it it's the idea that
we're all gonna die
is that not momentum all going to die
like again embrace harsh realities
you only have so much so
this is kind of cool when you think
about like okay i'm going to live until
i'm going to live to 90.
cool and feel like all right cool and
i'm in my early 30s
it doesn't put that much urgency into
anything
when you change it to how many summers
you have left
so you have 57 summers left
i said you're like whoa like summers go
by pretty quick
like yeah you only have 57 more summers
left and that's if you're
that's if you're in your 20s or 30s so
i'm now 44 years old
so now i get you know
40 something more summers left i gotta
make sure that each of those things
matter
now that's a summer now all you have to
do then from there is go like okay
we gotta make these weeks count then
okay we gotta make these
days count then okay we gotta make these
hours
and minutes and seconds count and when i
start to think about this this way
there's a there's there's a cost
to it like i can't sit through a movie
anymore i had i can't
i don't i don't know the last movie i've
watched people are like you got to watch
this show on netflix you know you got to
watch yellowstone you got to watch
breaking bad you got to watch mad men
you got to watch um game of thrones you
gotta
and i'm like i i've tried honestly i've
tried and it's
i can't do it like it's um to me i'm
i'm wasting my minutes i just it's not
moving me closer to my end goals now
what i could do
and if i could create the translation
between how this would help me
maximize those values then i can do it
i can sit through it i seek out
documentaries i love
documentaries because i'm learning in a
documentary that's one of my values
i love love love them i will watch four
documentaries back to back to back to
back because
whether it's about um you know jay-z
whether it's about a chef whether it's
about um
taylor swift whether it's about a soccer
team in england
whether it doesn't matter to me whether
it's about guys building shelters in the
jungle
any sort of like because to me i'm
learning and it's like
i that to me is maximizing my maximizing
my minutes
now i have a little bit more um
um my wife is a lot even more
tipped over the edge than i am on this
like my wife can't do anything that's
not productive
um she's but she meditates she reads
um she journal she does all these types
of spiritual practices
um but she can never just
um if she's sitting down that's sitting
down is for a purpose and i'm meditating
and what she's like she's so um
to her like every day matters so much
and we got to get as much value out of
every day as we possibly can
that's where it stems from but then when
it comes in terms of like me training my
world-class athletes
everyone is in the gym for six hours a
day at you and all of your competitors
in the gym for six hours a day
if you go to the gym more you're just
gonna over train that's not beneficial
if you go to the gym less you're gonna
under train so okay you have that set
amount of time what are you doing with
that time
and it's not a matter of like are you
rowing are you doing rogue climbs are
you clean and jerking
it's what's the intention and what's the
level of focus
you are bringing to those minutes he or
she who brings the most
intention to their training and practice
will win that's how it goes like
all else being equal meaning that
everyone has the same
athletic background everyone has the
same genetics everyone has the same
equipment same availability of
opportunities
he or she so everyone puts on the same
training program in a vacuum
laboratory study it's everyone knows
that
certain people are not going to people
are going to do better than other people
even if they're
twins and they have the same identity
makeup because some people are going to
bring more
intention to their practice to me that's
what maximizing minutes are
don't let the minutes slip away they are
the
people like to say that time is the most
valuable resource because the only
non-renewable resource
i like that and that's where this
maximize minutes idea comes from
but time is not the most valuable thing
your focus is the most valuable thing
what are you focusing on
during that time because
most of us that are 30 or 40 years old
have driven cars for 10 000 hours
yet none of us are professional race car
drivers because we're not intentional
when we drive
yet there's 16 17 18 year olds that are
knocking on the door being pros
that have driven half the time we have
but they're doing it with so much
intention and focus
so it's not the ten thousand hour rule
that malcolm gladwell
made really popular it's the deep
deliberate practice
that eric anderson originally espoused
in his ten thousand hour study
that's the thing that matters that's
maximizing your minutes
if everyone gets ten thousand hours why
do some people come better than others
because some people maximize their
minutes others don't i'm gonna guess
that you're familiar with cal newport's
deep work and he's got a formula
in that for work done and he says work
done equals time times
intensity and i guess that you could
replace intensity for intentionality
yeah yeah i love that intention here the
interesting thing
is that time passes at the same speed
for all of us
you can't add more hours into the day
and
time actually to compete on that there's
a minimum buy-in as you said you've got
to pay the price you've got to do six
hours
but six hours is always going to be six
hours and it's six hours for everybody
else
the variable with which you can change
is the level
of intensity far more easily you're
gonna be able to change the intensity
the intentionality the level of
commitment and focus that you bring to
the gym
or any other task that you do far more
easily than you're going to be able to
bend the laws of space time
so that's the thing that's the variable
to play around with
there's another another concept from the
e-myth um
revisited where they say that idea is
the constant
execution is the multiplier a lot of the
time people come in and they think i've
got this i've got this awesome idea but
like i'm gonna have to get you to sign a
non-disclosure agreement before we talk
about it
and you're like dude like joe rogan
isn't necessarily the best podcaster
on the planet because he had the idea
for the best podcast
he's the best podcaster on the planet
because he has executed on that
over and over and over again for 1500
times
and what you said in the commitment side
basically was a bias for action
it's you need to execute more than you
plan
you cannot plan more than you execute
it's this like
masturbation by procrastination type
thing that you just continue to make
yourself feel good with this
but it needs to be action focused and
again with this
a good heuristic that i think everybody
can do is as soon as you have the
beginning of an idea what is the
smallest next step that i can do that
brings me towards that happening
even if it's just opening the word
document
finding the person's email address even
before you know what you're going to
email them because it's like right i'm
i'm doing a thing learn to buy us
for action not bias for planning because
as you say planning it doesn't manifest
in the real world it's not moving you
anywhere forward
yeah exactly yeah we can sit here all
the time and talk you know wax nostalgia
about all the things that we find
important to us
but you don't take action towards those
things like what's it for so you what
you've done
in both of these sections in maximizing
minutes and in your commitment
your commitment is i want to ensure that
my daily actions contribute to my
long-term goals
i want to ensure that my minutes
contribute to a life well lived
you've taken broad goals a direction
that i want to go in
you've broken those down into sub goals
and you've broken those down into daily
actions that are going to contribute and
move you in that direction
that i think to some people
might feel overbearing like i haven't
got any time to chill out
or what about ben says he doesn't he
feels like every minute's got to be
productive like that doesn't sound very
fun
how do you avoid burnout when you're
moving towards
this maximizing minutes and this level
of commitment yeah what i'm what i'm
what i'm doing is i'm being intentional
with the things that actually make me
feel most alive
that give me the most feeling of
um joy and elation it doesn't mean that
it's join elation in the moment
like if we only chase pleasure we're
gonna end up with a world of regret at
the end like the most pleasurable things
in the world
are like ice cream partying netflix
sex like whatever it is like that's
pleasure if we just seek that we're
gonna be
you know hedonistic slobs what we should
be seeking out is
the things that move us towards the end
state that we're
that we're looking for which is for me
is fulfillment so
it's a little bit of this like exercise
of hindsight in the present moment
right it's like on my deathbed when i
look back in my life
what are the things that i can be really
glad that i did what are the ways i'm
going to be glad that i spent my time
what are the things that i'm i'm i'm
hoping um
are the ways that i'm living out my life
and i don't think that i'm gonna go like
man i was so glad
i watched um you know those four hours
of instagram today
so it's one of the things i've done in
terms of like trying to like i i
track my instagram like how much time
i'm spending on it it was i was
horrified to find when i first started
doing this that
it's super easy to do on an iphone you
go settings battery
change it to hours and look down and see
which and i was spending like
four or six hours oh in a 10-day span on
instagram
i was like oh my god and then i had my
athletes pull up theirs and it was like
double that i was like whoa this is
terrible
so i did what i do in my life i started
editing it down i'm down to i follow 44
people
um 44 different things and most of it is
just purely
um i think that instagram is this
double-edged thing which is it's also
the greatest education tool that's ever
been created
like it's a mate you get more content
easily through that
platform than any other platform ever um
which i think is so cool but
there's also there's a lot of dangers to
it so i'm now down to about
um 44 minutes in a 10-day period
so four minutes and four minutes a day
so
that's just like i it's it's not
pleasure
it's not it's not the thing that i want
to be doing so i'm not saying like you
have to live
your life as a robot at all what i'm
doing is i'm not wasting time
mindlessly on the things that i think
are making me feel good
which is actually a fallacy because it's
just a fake dopamine response
i you don't want to get tricked by
feelings
feelings are lying to us they're lying
to us
they're going to make us because it's
survival mechanisms we are calorie
preservation machines we want used to
like go and do a
a 90-minute hunt and then we wouldn't go
and leave the campfire for the rest of
the day
we just lounge out preserving calories
we go forage for berries for
30 minutes and we chill out forever like
that doesn't serve us anymore
and this idea of like the netflix
binging of watching
nine episodes in a row of gossip girl
i think i'm getting at the end of that
and be like okay
where did that help me live my life
where did that help me love more and
create better stronger relationships
people mean the most in my life
where they help me lead other people
help give back
where to help me learn the curiosity and
grow myself as a human being
and maybe gossip girl would give me some
good tips yeah maybe
there's a there's a concept i was
thinking about for a long time so just
like sorry if i i do like doing other
things though like i go like in the
summer i love going on a boat with my
family and going to a beach and hanging
out like
that i do i love that love love i do
that
i go skiing with my family and do things
like that i do watch
documentaries i do like um so i'm not
just like 100
robot machine go go go um
but to me it's about the balance and the
intentionality
right i want the balance of my life i
don't want to be the most successful
business person
i don't even want to be the most awesome
dad is really
strange and weird is that for me to say
out loud because i want to be able to do
four or five different things really
really well across the spectrum
there's a a concept that i've been
thinking about for a long time to do
with your future self
so we have three cells we have the past
self
that we remember we have the present
self that is experiencing and we have
the future self that we anticipate
right the
person that remembers your life lives
for far
far far longer than the other two the
present moment's always fleeting
it comes and goes the anticipating self
only has a fairly sort of short window
about what you think is going to happen
in the future
but the remembering self exists
literally from the day you're born
until the day that you die and it
compounds over time
so what i've been trying to do in my
life is
live for the remembering self to do the
things that i know
me tomorrow are going to thank me today
for doing
and there's a quote from a ted talk that
says we pamper the present
the present self like a child that
continues to cry
we constantly do things that make the
present self feel good
um we're planning on going to a new
salsa class tomorrow
the anticipating self thinks amazing
salsa class that might be really cool i
might meet some new people
but it gets to the next day and it's
salsa class time
and it's a bit cold outside and you had
a bit of a shitty day and maybe that
glass of wine would be quite nice and
netflix is comfortable and i'm on the
couch
present self pampered child remembering
self tomorrow
looks back and thinks i don't i can't
even remember what i watched the glass
of wine was all right but i've had a
million of them before it doesn't really
matter
flip that around and be the person who
says okay
i'm going to do the salsa class i'm
going to go and attend
because i know tomorrow when i look back
i'm going to gift
this present moment to me in the future
this is every single present moment is a
gift that i can give myself
money in the bank memories in the bank
and i'm going to be able to look back
and remember the new people that i met
and that memory that happened
we do nothing memorable with our days
and then complain about the fact that
life is forgotten
life's going so fast it just keeps on
moving really really quickly
like if you want to remember the days
that you've spent you have to do
something memorable with them
and a lot of the time i think we get
stuck into very convenient
very comfortable routines and that is
what makes
this last year the last 12 months will
have been
probably for the vast a lot of people
that are listening the quickest 12
months of their life
why because variety's been tuned down
you haven't been able to go and do
as many different things as you want
you're sick of staring at the same four
walls
so yeah if there was ever a reason a
justification for you to focus on doing
things for your
remembering self in the future it should
be that
yeah that's really cool um have you done
salsa classes
i did so i learned something for like my
this my second ever girlfriend
uh she was like a professional salsa
dancer so i took secret salsa classes
for
a month uh oh did you really yeah i did
it's such a romantic such a romantic man
um yeah that's really cool there's i
there there's a potential danger that
lies
inside of that i i think
um which is you could just be constantly
chasing the next high
chasing the next activity for the sake
of the activity
so um this is like the adrenaline
junkies this is my former life i was a
ski bum i would just like
i i chased the the next snowstorm i
chased the next
pow-pow day you know it was sickie
bluebee shred the pow-pow sector richter
buddy bro i don't know
what any of that means that's that's
like that's like
skiers are like surfers in a sense they
have like their own language
um so but that's what it was and what
you've what i found out with after doing
this for two or three years
is yes you have a lot of really cool
experiences
but are they truly fulfilling you
you have to start with that like what
are the things that are going which is
for me like
if it's a matter of like you just said
like the glass of wine um and the
netflix or the salsa class
if it's a salsa class by myself or the
glass of wine and netflix with my wife
i'm going to choose the glass of wine in
netflix with my wife because
i know that that's going to fulfill me
that's the thing that's going to
move the needle in terms of my own um
my own um the direction
i want to go towards and i think it's
really easy for people just to fill
their days with it's the opposite of the
laziness is to fill their days with
active activities
because it's a distraction from
figuring out truly what they want
i think you're right talking about
adversity
it's something that i think is missing
in a lot of people's lives and then can
exist in extremes in other people's
lives like the athletes that you coach
how can people learn to embrace
adversity
um so adversity is it's essentially
hard things right so it's whether it's
covid
the pandemic um whether it's
um it's raining outside or there's
traffic or whether it's
um a hard workout
the first thing we have to realize is
this is a part of life like
it's a it's the most important thing is
this acceptance level
we are not as human beings or any other
living thing on planet earth
not going to face adversity like every
there's a study done uh where these
scientists try to grow um try to create
utopia
this perfect garden and they put in this
dome in the desert with the perfect
humidity the perfect
amount of rain the perfect soil and
um they tried to make this perfect place
and once the trees got to a certain
height they just started toppling over
and what they found out was the trees
need
resistance they need wind to grow strong
without the wind there's without
resistance they're gonna be weak
they're not gonna they're not gonna be
able to fulfilled their own
destinies of being trees
it's we in our space and the people that
do like our our sport and
um it's just known like the heart if you
work hard
you're going to reap better results so
why would we not just kind of like
embrace it like why would not just kind
of seek this out
and the reason is because you're afraid
you're gonna fail
um so the example would be like let's
say one of my athletes is at the
crossfit games
and a um and
it's really really hot out
okay like that's gonna make it harder
yes
it's gonna make it harder so the first
is that you have to accept that like
it's outside your control
okay and then from there it's like it's
this hot for everybody
okay and then from there it's best thing
is like
why would you want it any other way like
you're at the crossfit games don't you
want this to be hard
it's a david goggins thing like if
you're gonna go through hell week give
me the coldest
hardest freaking hell week ever i don't
want this easy hell week
i don't want the one that people go like
yeah but that wasn't a tough one give it
to me like i'm going through this for a
reason
that's our lives we're going this for a
reason now
i also want the sunshine and rainbows
and i also want to um you know the grass
to be green and to enjoy myself but i
also
i also want the struggle and i really
mean that i want
the struggle when covid first happened
um you know i own i own a small business
and i thought i might lose the business
i own a gym
and gyms were closing down we closed the
gym and it was a day it was
a couple days filled with anxiety and
when i started to figure out like okay
like we just talked about like action
cures anxiety like just start
moving forward taking steps like you
said i just started writing lists of the
things i need to do i need to like
start taking action and as i started
going to i started get this like
this like early on the thing i hadn't
had for 10 years like it was like
i'm fighting for my survival again and
it was the best
a couple weeks of business ownership
that i've had
since i started my business that's what
we wax nostalgia about
is the or the days that are the hardest
nobody goes like with their team at
their you know their business and goes
remember those three months where it was
like really smooth sailing we all went
home at 4 45
and um you know we were just meeting the
numbers and everything was kind of just
like
hunky-dory and you know it's kind of
blah
like people go remember we stayed up
that weekend and we till
two in the morning getting that project
done we ordered pizza and we were
burning the midnight oil
and like we came in just under deadline
and we crushed it like
how that's what people remember
is your point is like create the
memories like the adversity
is the opportunity for us to get better
and talk about in terms of one of your
core values in mind from learning your
curiosity
like what better you need
that moment like if you're going to be
curious about something as you said like
i got this feeling like oh that warmness
in my neck like
what does that come from like that
didn't come from the warm and fuzzies
that came from a bad feeling adversity
and now you get to dig into it and
expose things and learn things become
better from it
i love it man i am i really think
that some of the lessons that come from
adversity in retrospect
are the ones that we really relish and
if you tell someone that in advance
it sounds so dumb but
60 what two-thirds of people report
post-traumatic growth not post-traumatic
stress
so the trauma makes them stronger they
are anti-fragile
i had a an achilles rupture full
achilles tear
at the middle of last year playing
cricket which is like
the most british way to rupture an
achilles
[Laughter]
and um in like a four day long qriket
match
no no in my first return to the game in
a decade which was
obviously just as stupid um
what happened when i ruptured my
achilles was i found
in myself a level of fortitude that i
didn't know existed
i didn't think i would have a
particularly good constitution to deal
with this sort of
trauma and something happened
i'd spent a fair bit of time there's a
lot of ryan holiday in ross edgeley but
like i did i did a bit of prep but then
like
when i needed it it was cold like when i
when i needed that fortitude to arrive
it was there
and now i have so much more faith
in future me i believe that
the things that if something occurs that
i don't think i'm capable of doing
if i need to my constitution will get me
through it
there's like areas of my programming
that i can't access
unless they're needed you said at the
very beginning the woman that pulls the
car off the infant
there are things that you can do that
you don't know that you can do
and for the for the most part you're not
crew
or the pilot on spaceship human you are
[ __ ] cargo
you are along for the ride and your
program is running the show
and for you to think that you know the
levels and the limits of your potential
is it
you're believing the the hype in a way
that is
not only untrue but also not productive
you can do things that you don't know
that you can do and you won't know that
you can do them until you need to
boom talking about confidence i want to
know
how people can build confidence
it's just preparation i mean it's the
same it's the same word like people are
confusing like
um if they're trying to create
confidence you don't create it
it confidence is a side effect it's the
result
of something feel like you okay go on
the field and be confident it's like
what like get on that stage and be
confident
what no you you earn confidence
through your preparation if you put in
the work you know that you can do this
now what i would ask of my athletes and
what i would coach people to do
is to define success in controllable
terms
and when you start to do that confidence
becomes a lot more attainable
because if confidence is i'm going to
win while winning and results are
outside your control
so now how in the world could you be
confident when you don't even
when you have you have no direct impact
on the end result of what you're doing
so if you define success in you know
regardless of the adversity regardless
of the circumstances regardless of the
score regardless of what happens
i am going to give my very best effort
through this
okay that you can yeah cool if you yeah
if you know you can do that that's
confidence that's what that is and then
if you bring
a high level of preparation to that
endeavor now we're really talking
because that's what it is
then really whatever situation pops up
is probably not gonna be new like
imagine you're a football team or
whatever it might be or um a business
navigating a new situation well if
you've
prepared for those situations you can be
confident for sure
but i think people um think that they
can
call upon confidence and you can't call
upon confidence
it's the net end result of
preparation and effort confidence needs
to be earned there's a naval ravicant
quote where he says
self-esteem is the reputation you have
with yourself you'll always know
and i think we look at people because we
only get to see that
the outward display of confidence and
you see
beyonce on stage or matt fraser at the
games or
some cool dancer person up on a stage
somewhere
and you think like look at that
confidence and you go well
what's the difference between confidence
and
so much preparation that you know even
your worst effort is far better than you
need it to be
yeah right that yes
that's confidence exactly right
what advice would you have for a young
guy or girl who feels like they've
sort of built for more than they're
currently achieving so they're stuck in
a
bit of a mediocrity rut and they know
that they've got potential but they're
just
they're kind of bogged down like is
there a realization that you can give
them to snap out
of it yeah it's a great question um
yeah i don't know if it's a matter of i
don't think that snapping out of it
really exists and
without the work right like so if you've
done
your thousand days of meditation you
might have this snap moment but it's
coming from the other
thousands of days that you've done this
so to me
it it kind of starts with that first
piece that we talked about which is
um
like pull yourself out of the matrix
right like the the operating system that
you which you
the words that you use which i love is
there is this either already self
designed program running you and then
you're also inside
of the matrix where the society is just
guiding you and basically you're just
kind of like
trying to walk down the hall without
bumping into the walls like
that's not like pop your head up
and look at the entire maze and go like
wait a minute
wait wait a minute i don't even want to
i don't want to be in this game i want
to go play that game over there
so if people are feeling bogged down if
they're feeling
like they have so much more attainable i
would say that you probably do
and if you can't figure out what that
thing is that you want to do
so what you said chris is like i would
just go start having some experiences
like you just need to start experiencing
things because you learn so much more
through experience and action
than you ever will sitting and
um staying stuck
you can't i i'm a big fan of
um fast big decisions
like when 911 happened i was working
in a bank in boston like an investment
bank
and um that was enough for me to
that was a snap moment for me and i was
like
um this is not for me i don't want to
play this game i'm going to go i want to
have impact um
i left the investment world moved out to
wyoming
um to try to get some space and some
solitude and be a ski bum
and figure out what i want to do with my
life and that's when i came across that
i i was like i want to do fitness like
this what's the thing that this is when
i feel alive
so one of my one of my principles one of
my like guiding
guideposts is blur the line between work
and play
like i love doing this with you chris
like if i was like am i
like am i at work right now or am i
playing right now
right it's the same thing like when i'm
coaching my athletes
like that's i'm not working like i'm
doing what i love to do
and when i'm running and leading the
business like that's what i love to do
and when i i don't mondays and saturdays
are the same like it's just like i'm all
like find something that you love to do
i know this is so cliche it's the most
cliche thing in the world
but i thought i loved to ski so i went
out to become a ski bum
and that's when i realized it wasn't
just chasing the next big wave or the
next storm
that didn't really ultimately fulfill me
i wanted more
so then i made the next big decision
which was let's move back and start a
training business and
just start going and doing that and if
you fail you fail like
when i did the you know there's plenty
of things that i did that like
i was i would say that i failed at but i
don't really believe in failure i just
don't think it's a thing
i think that you do things and you
you just learn from them you just kind
of and you have another experience and
you learn from that
and some of them come out the way you
expected them to and some don't come out
the way you expected them to
but it's not a matter of
successes or failures because even
success
on whose terms like we don't know
the scoreboard of life so how are we
going to time
to find successes so that's why to me
it's
i've come down to this fulfillment word
which is don't chase
joy don't chase pleasure but certainly
don't chase what mom and dad told you to
do
or what society's telling you to do
certainly don't just do what you're
doing now because
it's what you did yesterday and the day
before and the day before that and the
day before that
pop your head up take a look around and
go what do i want with
my life um
and when you come to that answer maybe
ask yourself why a couple times because
it's the asking yourself why so we have
this thing like ask yourself
the five whys so um
you know i wanna start um
i just wanna i just wanna get um
i wanna go i wanna ski why because like
uh it makes me feel
uh i want the the freedom and the
experience and she's like you keep
backing up and we find out is
there wasn't a good why behind that but
it's like i want to
um start a training business why it's
like i
ended up coming all the way back to like
i just feel this incredible
responsibility to turn people from
potentially liabilities to assets my
biggest fear is that i'm a liability to
my family actually my family is my is
the whole jam
and my biggest fear is that my family
has to take care of me at some point
and i i just want to be able to be like
grandpa's here and go like
skiing with them and like do all this
really cool fun stuff like i want to be
an asset
at all times and i want to be able to do
that for other people and that's the
reason why like that's
that's my thing i want to be able to um
make other people's lives better by
being a part of it
like i i just want to um and i want to
be able to do that for other people and
that's a pretty powerful why for me
that's enough to like
get me really really excited to get at 5
15 every morning
and when you can ask yourself that one
thing that you go
yeah that's the thing maybe we won't be
as stuck
that's it man i think the best heuristic
for whether or not you
your life has meaning is are you excited
to get out of bed or not
if you're excited to get out of bed in
the morning you have a reason to if
you're not
i think that there's probably some
questions to be asked one thing
you've kept on using the word
fulfillment throughout this conversation
what i think is fulfillment is
excellence
with meaning the excellence without
meaning
can be perfection for the for its own
sake
but excellence with meaning is
excellence with direction
it's going toward a thing i gotta i
gotta ask
i got a last question i got asked this
on twitter the other day and it was
really good so i'm gonna ask you it as
well
what do you think ben 10 years from now
would advise ben now
it's a question i ask myself a lot and
that's kind of
um how i got to where i am tracking all
this stuff and thinking about
um this kind of hindsight in pers
in this present moment right now is i
think i would go
hey it's important that you
have some levels of success from the
business thing like i think
you're gonna find a lot of fulfillment
out of that i think you're gonna feel
value out of that that seems to be like
something that you should chase
but more so and equally as important or
like let's not forget about
also your family and also let's also
continue to learn things as well and so
the biggest thing for me is that i i
want to create this balance across
you know if if life is made up of um
family career hobbies
spirituality health and maybe another
thing like
my kind of objective is to try to sort
of like
balance those at all points not a seesaw
but like a a frisbee on a pencil where
not every you know nothing tips too much
it might swing a little bit one way or
the other
but i've seen too many times friends and
um you know parents of my friends that
have chased one of those things too far
and um
it affects all the others and what i'm
trying to do is create
um
that balance to to achieve what i think
is um
hopefully going to lead to a fulfilled
life you know i think along with that is
like
the thing i'm trying to learn a little
bit through this uh meditation practice
would be
so i'm answering this question twice um
like let it go bro like just like this
ego thing this
like this subconscious pattern
recognition thing that we have of like
this need to be right and this need for
um attention and this need for
um
you know
i don't know what i mean i'm pretty you
know it's kind of weird because i have a
podcast i wrote a book and i like
i have a social media platform but i'm a
very introverted person
so um when people are introverted it's
kind of like well
that person doesn't have much of an ego
um but ego is more than just like
the need to be in the the spotlight on
them and all that the ego is like
um it's so powerful
and um
potentially destructive and i think it
would
i think my future self would go um
try to be more at peace
in harmony with those around you
and just connect more with people
because i think that at the end of the
day
you know in terms of like we were
talking about like chasing experiences
i think if you're chasing connection
whatever the experiences you have
whether it's sitting and meditating with
somebody
literally kind of like doing nothing or
bungee jumping it doesn't really matter
because it's the connections we have
people
that are probably going to matter the
most that's such like a
fortune cookie way to end a podcast
i think it's right man the trajectory
that everyone can look to to kind of
predict where they're going to end up
is where older people are and the vast
majority of older people if you look at
them they're not
bothered about like your grandparents
aren't bothered about what car they
drive not necessarily bothered about
what shoes they're wearing
not really even too bothered they've
stopped playing status games
like what are the things that they're
concerned about they've simplified their
life down
they've probably got a little bit more
conservative politically
they are not so bothered about sort of
chasing pennies
but they're fairly concerned about going
to church on sunday
or going to play balls with their
friends or
the whatever night they have with their
partner
that's what they care about and we can
almost
look the same way as evolution works
evolution of life
evolution of a philosophy within a life
that's quite easy to look at just look
at the people that are older than you
what are they doing
that's probably where you're going to
end up man this um
this has been awesome i uh uh we've
waited for a long time i'm very very
glad
that we did if people want to check out
comptrain download the app do all that
stuff where should they go
yeah um comptrain uh just
google comp train it'll pop right up um
otherwise it's in the app store
that's the uh it's the training program
that we have um
yeah that's it's as easy as that the
google machine knows where to go chasing
excellence the book will be linked below
along with ben and patrick's fantastic
podcast
which i continue to listen to
man it's appreciated chris thanks man
the stuff that you do there dude
thank you for today you got it party
thank you
[Music]